Alice:太牛逼了
Katrina: 然后还要干什么
Katrina: So, what else to do?
Shure: 然后烧炭就可以起锅
Shure: Then just charcoal it and you can start cooking.
Katrina: 烧炭
Katrina: Charcoal it.
Shure: 开始一会我不知道
Shure: Start, I don't know.
Shure: 这个咸蛋我有点掌握不好
Shure: I can't quite handle this salted egg.
Shure: 然后一会如果淡了
Shure: So if it's bland later...
Alice:直接就是巨大的面团
Alice: It's just a huge dough.
Jake:这是什么肉啊
Jake: What meat is this?
Jake:这都牛肉和鸡肉
Jake: It's all beef and chicken.
Shure: 这全是牛肉
Shure: It's all beef.
Shure: 然后这是鸡肉和排骨
Shure: And this is chicken and ribs.
Jake:哟看起来很厉害
Jake: Wow, looks impressive.
Shure: 绝绝对香
Shure: Absolutely delicious.
Shure: 跟你讲
Shure: Let me tell you
Shure: 一般不来长春都尝不到这手艺的
Shure: You usually can't taste this craft unless you come to Changchun
Alice:酸啊
Alice: It's sour
Shure: 今儿是偷偷漏抖都给你们了
Shure: Today, I'm giving you a secret tip
Jake:行
Jake: Okay
Lucia: 是烤的话是要在外面烤吗
Lucia: If it's grilled, do we grill it outside?
Shure: 这比我女朋友都早
Shure: This is earlier than my girlfriend
Jake:对那边有个好家
Jake: Yeah, there's a good spot over there
Shure: 迟了两周
Shure: Two weeks late
Shure: 我跟你讲
Shure: Let me tell you
Jake:啊早谁谁早吃那两周啊
Jake: Ah, who ate two weeks earlier?
Shure: 啊
Shure: Ah
Shure: 比我女朋友
Shure: Earlier than my girlfriend
Jake:他还没吃
Jake: He hasn't eaten yet
Jake:行
Jake: Okay
Shure: 那我们周日是还要弄这些是吗
Shure: So are we doing this on Sunday too?
Jake:对周日还要弄
Jake: Yeah, we'll do it on Sunday too
Shure: 啊那应该也能吃
Shure: Ah, then we should be able to eat
Alice:周日不是不吃饭吗
Alice: Aren't we not eating on Sunday?
Alice:就是加冰
Alice: Just add ice
Jake:这烤烤一点
Jake: Just grill a little
Katrina: 好一点
Katrina: A bit better
Alice:哦提前搞一点
Alice: Oh, prepare a bit ahead
Katrina: 好一
Katrina: Better
Shure: 意思一下懂了吧
Shure: You get the idea, right?
Jake:你的意思一下
Jake: Your idea
Jake:或者剩一点给他哈哈哈
Jake: Or save some for him, haha
Lucia: 这外头除了那圈墙
Lucia: Outside, besides that wall
Alice:啊剩一点
Alice: Ah, save some
Alice:哈哈哈真嘟假嘟
Alice: Haha, really?
Lucia: 外头是不除了那圈墙灯没有别的灯了
Lucia: Outside, besides that wall light, there's no other light
Jake:对
Jake: Yeah
Lucia: 啊
Lucia: Ah
Jake:就是这5个灯
Jake: Just these 5 lights
Jake:我我可以去打光
Jake: I can light it up
Jake:就是你要什么灯吗
Jake: Do you need any lights?
Lucia: 哦没有没有
Lucia: Oh, no
Lucia: 不是我是说如果要在外面烤的话
Lucia: No, I mean if we're grilling outside
Lucia: 外面其实还有点黑
Lucia: It's a bit dark outside
Jake:啊对没关系
Jake: Ah, it's fine
Alice:火一点起来应该好一点吧
Alice: Maybe lighting the fire a bit more would help.
Jake:这氛围到位了
Jake: The atmosphere is just right now.
Lucia: 对
Lucia: Yeah.
Lucia: 但是只有那个就是炉子那里会亮一点
Lucia: But only the stove area is a bit brighter.
Lucia: 咱们吃饭的桌子还挺黑的啊
Lucia: Our dining table is still quite dark though.
Jake:嗯
Jake: Mhm.
Lucia: 不过有那个那个影棚灯
Lucia: But we have those studio lights.
Alice:先找点纸盒点火吧
Alice: Let's find some cardboard to start the fire.
Alice:还是有火枪啥的
Alice: Or maybe we have a lighter or something.
Shure: 没事
Shure: It's okay.
Shure: 呃我想想我下一步要
Shure: Uh, let me think about what I need to do next.
Shure: 做什么呃
Shure: What should I do, uh...
Shure: 这些也可以拿出来
Shure: We can take these out too.
Shure: 羊排
Shure: Lamb chops.
Shure: 大蒜都拿着吃
Shure: Grab the garlic too.
Shure: 肉不吃蒜香味少一半呢
Shure: Meat without garlic loses half its flavor.
Alice:你今天晚上想吃这个吗
Alice: Do you want to eat this tonight?
Alice:那我们打开吧
Alice: If so, let's open it.
Lucia: 可以吃好的
Lucia: We can eat it, sure.
Alice:这个蜂蜜给你
Alice: Here's the honey for you.
Lucia: 哦你不你不用这个行
Lucia: Oh, you don't, you don't need this?
Jake:大师我们做什么呀
Jake: Master, what should we do?
Alice:我不吃蜂蜜的
Alice: I don't eat honey.
Shure: 大师
Shure: Master.
Alice:大师你要蒜吗
Alice: Master, do you want garlic?
Shure: 不是别别
Shure: No, no.
Jake:哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha.
Shure: 大师蒜拿生吃的
Shure: Master eats garlic raw.
Tasha: 不要
Tasha: No.
Alice:啊
Alice: Ah.
Shure: 对然后把把生菜洗了吧
Shure: Yeah, and then wash the lettuce.
Shure: 来个人把生菜洗了
Shure: Someone wash the lettuce.
Alice:生吃大蒜
Alice: Raw garlic.
Jake:生菜
Jake: Lettuce.
Shure: 没吃过吧
Shure: You've never tried it, right?
Shure: 尝尝就知道了
Shure: Try it and you'll see.
Lucia: 可以生吃而且就是跟肉在一起
Lucia: You can eat it raw, especially with meat.
Alice:我知道了但是我觉得比较奇怪
Alice: I know, but I find it a bit strange.
Jake:怎么洗
Jake: How do you wash it?
Shure: 生生菜就是洗洗菜
Shure: Just wash the lettuce like you wash vegetables.
Lucia: 挺好吃的
Lucia: Pretty tasty.
Lucia: 只不过就是吃完之后会有蒜味
Lucia: But it leaves a garlic taste after eating.
Shure: 咋洗他咋洗知道不
Shure: Do you know how to wash it?
Shure: 拿个盆装里面
Shure: Put it in a basin.
Shure: 然后把生菜洗了
Shure: Then wash the lettuce.
Lucia: 所以一般很少这样
Lucia: That's why we rarely do it like this.
Jake:干哈干哈干哈
Jake: What are you doing, what are you doing?
Jake:咱要干嘛
Jake: What are we supposed to do?
Shure: 就是把生菜洗
Shure: Just wash the lettuce.
Jake:洗洗生菜
Jake: Wash the lettuce.
Shure: 就剩生菜没洗了啊
Shure: The lettuce is the only thing left to wash.
Shure: 那个土豆
Shure: The potatoes.
Alice:生菜没洗
Alice: The lettuce isn't washed.
Shure: 土豆想吃的话就削了
Shure: If you want to eat the potatoes, peel them.
Shure: 然后切成片
Shure: Then slice them.
Alice:开开瓶
Alice: Open the bottle.
Jake:行啊
Jake: Okay.
Katrina: 好了麻烦你们起一下这个
Katrina: Alright, could you guys get this done?
Alice:我没有盆吗
Alice: Do I have a basin?
Jake:没有吧
Jake: I don't think so.
Jake:这锅怎么长这样这锅怎么长这样
Jake: Why does this pot look like this, why does it look like this?
Alice:有人要纯酸奶吗
Alice: Does anyone want plain yogurt?
Alice:比较酸的
Alice: It's quite sour.
Jake:这锅为什么长成这个样子
Jake: Why does this pot look like this?
Jake:可以吃可以吃
Jake: It's edible, it's edible.
Lucia: 嗯那就3个
Lucia: Okay, then three.
Alice:纯酸奶无糖的好
Alice: Plain yogurt without sugar is good.
Jake:嗯可以吃
Jake: Yeah, it's edible.
Tasha: 好没事
Tasha: Alright, no problem.
Lucia: 没事我可以把这个蜂蜜分享给你
Lucia: No problem, I can share this honey with you.
Alice:还有人吗还有人吗
Alice: Anyone else? Anyone else?
Lucia: 白砂糖也可以加
Lucia: You can add white sugar too.
Tasha: 其实还有人吗
Tasha: Actually, anyone else?
Alice:还有人吗
Alice: Anyone else?
Jake:好
Alice:微微你是纯酸奶吗
Alice: Tasha, do you want plain yogurt?
Alice:那我们3个
Alice: Then three of us.
Lucia: 行那我拿两个碗
Lucia: Okay, then I'll get two bowls.
Lucia: 正好我刚洗完眉那个玩意
Lucia: I just finished washing that thing for my eyebrows.
Shure: 嗯
Shure: Yeah.
Alice:咋了
Alice: What's wrong?
Shure: 这也没放油
Shure: There's no oil in this.
Shure: 想起来了
Shure: Just remembered.
Jake:发生什么事
Jake: What happened?
Shure: 是吧是没放油吧再倒点
Shure: Right, there's no oil. Let's add some more.
Shure: 你看看不行了吧
Shure: Look, it's not working, right?
Lucia: 我把我把手再冲一下去
Lucia: I'll go rinse my hands again.
Alice:不放油也行吧
Alice: It's fine without oil, right?
Lucia: 我刚抓了那个生蚝袋子
Lucia: I just grabbed that oyster bag.
Shure: 不不行不行
Shure: No, no, it's not fine.
Shure: 得放下去
Shure: We need to add it.
Alice:你考的时候不是也要刷他吗
Alice: Don't you need to brush it when you grill?
Shure: 不刷不刷
Shure: No brushing.
Shure: 直接烤
Shure: Just grill directly.
Alice:不刷呦
Alice: No brushing, huh?
Jake:丢我嫌丢
Jake: I don't like it.
Shure: 对
Shure: Yep.
Shure: 拿筷子别上手了
Shure: Use chopsticks, don't use your hands.
Alice:碗呢
Alice: Where's the bowl?
Shure: 让你偷学
Shure: Trying to steal my techniques?
Shure: 你都不学全了
Shure: You didn't learn everything.
Katrina: 哈哈哈哈
Katrina: Hahaha.
Shure: 然后到时候出去骂教的不对退钱
Shure: Then you'll complain that I taught you wrong and ask for a refund.
Katrina: 哈到时候出去别说我是修硕学生
Katrina: Haha, just don't mention you're Shure's student when you go out.
Alice:嗯我给你这个芒果今天晚上要吃的
Alice: Hmm, I'll give you this mango. We'll eat it tonight.
Alice:拿个勺之类的
Alice: Grab a spoon or something.
Alice:这好像没有勺吧
Alice: Seems like there's no spoon here.
Jake:哎呦我去
Jake: Oh my goodness.
Alice:抱歉了
Alice: Sorry about that.
Alice:用这个
Alice: Use this.
Jake:这东西怎么这
Jake: How do you use this?
Jake:能擦干净吗这
Jake: Can this be cleaned?
Tasha: 不能就算了
Tasha: If not, forget it.
Alice:是不是有点抽象哈哈哈
Alice: Is it a bit abstract? Hahaha.
Tasha: 火吧
Tasha: Burn it.
Alice:确实有点抽象
Alice: It is a bit abstract.
Lucia: 这个不太好弄还是拿个那个
Lucia: This is tricky, better get that.
Lucia: 中午啊今天中午外卖没给勺
Lucia: At noon today, the takeout didn't come with spoons.
Lucia: 其他的勺还有用吗
Lucia: Are there any other spoons left?
Lucia: 咱一会吃的时候得用勺
Lucia: We'll need spoons when we eat later.
Lucia: 啊let me think
Lucia: Ah, let me think.
Lucia: 一次性餐具还有吗
Lucia: Do we still have disposable tableware?
Lucia: 一次那个一次性餐具
Lucia: The disposable tableware.
Lucia: 因为我们好像没什么勺
Lucia: Because it seems like we don't have any spoons.
Lucia: 然后现在要舀这个
Lucia: And we need them to scoop this.
Alice:我用筷子弄的给你选一个吧
Alice: I used chopsticks, let me get you one.
Lucia: 随便都行
Lucia: Anything is fine.
Lucia: 但是但是
Lucia: But, but...
Lucia: 关键在于
Lucia: The key is...
Lucia: 咱们吃的时候要用勺吃
Lucia: We need to use spoons while eating.
Alice:有点少
Alice: There aren't many.
Alice:我用筷子吧
Alice: I'll use chopsticks then.
Jake:咱要不买一点吧
Jake: How about we buy some?
Jake:买个外卖买
Jake: Order some with our takeout.
Lucia: 嗯哈哈哈哈哈哈
Lucia: Hmm, hahaha.
Jake:不是不是哈哈哈
Jake: No, no, hahaha.
Jake:就是外卖里面有配送这些商品的
Jake: I mean, takeout usually comes with these items.
Alice:给你选一个这
Alice: Let me pick one for you.
Jake:这这这有的选吗
Jake: Do I have a choice?
Jake:这个左边
Jake: The left one.
Alice:不一样吗
Alice: Aren't they the same?
Tasha: 对啊他写上
Tasha: Yeah, he wrote on it.
Jake:对啊那选啥
Jake: Yeah, so what's the choice?
Alice:差不多你随便选
Alice: They're almost the same, just pick one.
Jake:好谢谢
Jake: Okay, thanks.
Alice:这个给你放哪
Alice: Where should I put this for you?
Tasha: 好了不用擦了洗不掉了
Tasha: It's fine, no need to wipe it, it won't come off.
Lucia: 这个蜂蜜是一个勺型的
Lucia: This honey is in a spoon shape.
Lucia: 所以我我可以用这个蜂蜜勺吃它
Lucia: So, I can use this honey spoon to eat it.
Jake:我算洗完了吗
Jake: Am I done washing?
Tasha: 算现在要把它擦干
Tasha: Yes, now you need to dry it.
Tasha: 就是就是
Tasha: Just, just...
Tasha: 擦到看
Tasha: Wipe it until...
Alice:无油无水状态
Alice: It's oil and water free.
Tasha: 啊这个明显还有水
Tasha: Ah, there's still water on it.
Tasha: 你要拿新的纸再擦一下
Tasha: You need to use a new paper towel to wipe it again.
Jake:好
Jake: Okay.
Alice:你尝一口吗无糖的不好奇
Alice: Want to try a bite? It's sugar-free, aren't you curious?
Tasha: 嗯不尝
Tasha: Hmm, no thanks.
Shure: 来借个剪刀把碳打开
Shure: Can I borrow some scissors to open the charcoal?
Tasha: OK啦
Tasha: Okay then.
Tasha: 这包纸封在这就是专门擦他的
Tasha: This pack of tissues is specifically for wiping him.
Alice:渴吗
Alice: Thirsty?
Jake:哦没看见多少
Jake: Oh, I didn't see much.
Jake:还是瞎了点
Jake: Still a bit blind.
Tasha: 底部就不用擦了里面
Tasha: No need to wipe the bottom, just inside.
Jake:好
Jake: Okay.
Jake:爱擦就是要擦
Jake: If you like wiping, then wipe.
Tasha: 这
Tasha: This...
Shure: 来个帮我一起引碳的
Shure: Someone help me light the charcoal.
Alice:我来吧
Alice: I'll do it.
Lucia: 我马上我把这个搅好
Lucia: I'll do it right after I finish stirring this.
Jake:嗯
Jake: Hmm.
Jake:不行
Jake: No, it's not working.
Tasha: 这
Tasha: This...
Jake:嘿嘿嘿对不起
Jake: Haha, sorry.
Alice:算了放外面把
Alice: Forget it, just put it outside.
Alice:我来了
Alice: I'm coming.
Alice:是不是得给它弄开啊
Alice: Should we open it?
Alice:这么大块不好点吧
Alice: Such a big piece won't light easily.
Shure: 应该还行
Shure: It should be fine.
Alice:不太好印
Alice: Not easy to print.
Alice:我拿点纸箱
Alice: I'll get some cardboard.
Alice:哦酒精棉是吗
Alice: Oh, alcohol wipes?
Alice:干的
Alice: It's dry.
Shure: 像是硝酸那味
Shure: Smells like nitric acid.
Alice:这玩意有腐蚀性
Alice: This stuff is corrosive.
Shure: 没事
Shure: It's fine.
Alice:嗯好臭啊
Alice: Ugh, it stinks.
Shure: 然后拿个小纸壳演传递圣火
Shure: Then use a small piece of cardboard to pass the flame.
Alice:好
Alice: Okay.
Alice:拽两下呗
Alice: Pull it twice.
Shure: 撕撕你这撕这么大干啥你说
Shure: Why are you tearing such a big piece, you tell me?
Alice:这点够吗
Alice: Is this enough?
Shure: 够了够了
Shure: It's enough, it's enough.
Shure: 没事那也行
Shure: It's fine, that works too.
Jake:你问问看用
Jake: You ask if it can be used.
Shure: 只要是酒精就行
Shure: As long as it's alcohol, it's fine.
Alice:这个引碳引到啥时候去
Alice: How long will it take to light the charcoal?
Jake:不知道啊
Jake: No idea.
Lucia: 啊
Lucia: Ah
Alice:烧不起来
Alice: It's not lighting up.
Shure: 再再次引一次
Shure: Try igniting it again.
Shure: 有火吗主要咱没火
Shure: Is there a fire? We don't have a fire.
Jake:谢斌如不在是吧哈哈
Jake: Xie Binru isn't here, right? Haha
Shure: 对昨天应该把他火顺来的
Shure: Yeah, we should have brought the fire from yesterday.
Alice:所以我们的火是啥
Alice: So what is our fire?
Shure: 我的火就是煤气罐
Shure: My fire is a gas cylinder.
Alice:啊
Alice: Ah
Shure: 不是燃气灶
Shure: Not a gas stove.
Shure: 就是我们的火
Shure: Just our fire.
Alice:要不直接拿个碳在上面烧
Alice: How about we just burn some charcoal?
Alice:会中毒吗
Alice: Will it cause poisoning?
Alice:我姐拿个炭过去烧吧
Alice: My sister can burn some charcoal.
Jake:也也也对
Jake: Yeah, yeah, that's right.
Lucia: 今天是要做什么呢
Lucia: What are we doing today?
Shure: 应该成功了点
Shure: It should work a bit.
Tasha: 呃伯爵红茶
Tasha: Uh, Earl Grey tea.
Tasha: 芒果再搞点芒果吧
Tasha: Let's get some mangoes.
Tasha: 注意下注意下注意
Tasha: Be careful, be careful.
Alice:感觉我会太我感觉会太慢了
Alice: I feel like I will be too slow.
Alice:直接拿炭烧吧
Alice: Let's just burn charcoal.
Lucia: 碳让它燃起来
Lucia: Let the charcoal burn.
Lucia: 是不是得花点钱
Lucia: Doesn't it cost some money?
Lucia: 给先放点容易燃的东西之类的
Lucia: Put some flammable stuff first.
Alice:是他那个就是易燃物比较少
Alice: It's just that there aren't enough flammable materials.
Alice:就直接用碳吧
Alice: Let's just use charcoal.
Alice:反正守着煤气罐呢
Alice: Anyway, we're next to the gas cylinder.
Alice:的通好风
Alice: Make sure there's ventilation.
Alice:别一会给大家整一氧化碳中毒了
Alice: Don't want everyone getting carbon monoxide poisoning.
Alice:可以了吗
Alice: Is it ready?
Shure: 可以了走吧
Shure: It's ready, let's go.
Shure: 我说那边着了已经
Shure: I said it's already lit over there.
Shure: 他也着了
Shure: It's lit too.
Jake:咋吃呢
Jake: How do we eat it?
Lucia: 嗯一般来说你得拿个勺挖着吃
Lucia: Hmm, usually you scoop it with a spoon.
Lucia: 但这个装蜂蜜的勺已经被我征用了
Lucia: But I've already used the honey spoon.
Lucia: 所以
Lucia: So...
Alice:你可以跟我一样用筷子吃
Alice: You can use chopsticks like me.
Lucia: 对所以你就可以考虑用筷子吃
Lucia: Yeah, so you can consider using chopsticks.
Shure: 他解招了
Shure: He broke the move.
Alice:太好了直接扔里吧
Alice: Great, just throw it in.
Alice:给他扒拉进去
Alice: Push it in for him.
Alice:你这不把他扒拉进去吗
Alice: Aren't you gonna push it in?
Shure: 他他夹不动了
Shure: He can't hold it anymore.
Shure: 已经脆了这个
Shure: It's already crispy.
Shure: 这烧塑料
Shure: This is burning plastic.
Shure: 而且这条都是塑料
Shure: And this whole thing is plastic.
Shure: 狼烟起苍山
Shure: Smoke rising from the mountains.
Alice:我去
Alice: Oh my.
Alice:一会会不会熏黑呀
Alice: Will it get all smoky later?
Alice:如今新新换的衣服
Alice: I just changed into new clothes.
Alice:这一块灭了
Alice: This part is extinguished.
Alice:哈哈哈哈哈哈哈笑死我了
Alice: Hahahahahaha you're killing me.
Shure: 哎倒也行你别说
Shure: Well, it kinda works, don't you think?
Alice:是不是就是这样的
Alice: Isn't it supposed to be like this?
Shure: 卧槽好像是
Shure: Damn, it seems like it.
Shure: 好像是哎
Shure: It seems like it, yeah.
Shure: 哦对
Shure: Oh right.
Shure: 他放在底下卧槽
Shure: He put it at the bottom, damn.
Shure: 加大火势
Shure: Increase the fire.
Shure: 来给我都给他烧了
Shure: Come on, burn it all.
Alice:快熏死我了
Alice: It's suffocating me.
Alice:晚上玩火会怎么尿床
Alice: Playing with fire at night might make you wet the bed.
Shure: 但说实话有点不够
Shure: But to be honest, it's a bit lacking.
Shure: 但没有关系
Shure: But it's fine.
Alice:没事
Alice: It's okay.
Shure: 都快着了吧
Shure: It's almost burning, right?
Shure: 火化炉是不是不够了加
Shure: Is the cremator not enough? Add more.
Shure: 就哭哭烧
Shure: Just burn it.
Shure: 别给他盖聂了
Shure: Don't cover it up.
Alice:这是可以录的吗
Alice: Can we record this?
Shure: 都着了吧这碳
Shure: It's all burning, this coal.
Shure: 还没着吗
Shure: Not burning yet?
Alice:没反应呢
Alice: No reaction yet.
Alice:经过我们的不懈努力
Alice: After our relentless effort,
Alice:这个炭终于受了一点皮外伤
Alice: this coal finally got a little scratch.
Shure: 这算是着了吧
Shure: This counts as burning, right?
Alice:没火星还是那半截烧着呢
Alice: No sparks, just that half is burning.
Shure: 这还是那半家烧的
Shure: This is still that half-baked one.
Alice:要不就给那个燃气炉上烧它得了
Alice: Why not just use the gas stove to burn it?
Alice:这火还没那个
Alice: This fire is not even...
Shure: 一根一根烧
Shure: Burn it stick by stick.
Alice:那其实烧够两三根
Alice: Actually, burning two or three sticks is enough.
Alice:用其他印就行了
Alice: Just use other prints and it will be fine.
Shure: 其实最快的方法就是加酒精
Shure: Actually, the fastest way is to add alcohol.
Jake:哦OK
Jake: Oh, OK.
Shure: 最快的方法就是加酒精啊
Shure: The fastest way is to add alcohol!
Alice:讲什么没听清
Alice: What did you say? I didn't hear clearly.
Alice:有酒精吗
Alice: Do we have alcohol?
Alice:要不喷点油得了
Alice: Or should we spray some oil?
Shure: 喷点油得了
Shure: Spray some oil then.
Shure: 油也不行吧
Shure: But oil might not work, right?
Alice:给这摊上喷点油
Alice: Spray some oil on this spot.
Alice:让他烧着
Alice: Let it burn.
Shure: 你给他又加回来的是吗
Shure: Did you add it back again?
Shure: 还是说他一直在这呢
Shure: Or is it still here?
Alice:没他就在这上边呢
Alice: No, it's just on top of here.
Jake:刷不完吗
Jake: Can't finish it?
Jake:烧烧 不起来吗
Jake: Burn it, can't it start?
Lucia: 总感觉这勺子可以留一下
Lucia: I always feel like this spoon can be kept.
Alice:这探看起来也就受了点皮外伤
Alice: This burn looks like it just has a surface wound.
Shure: 确实没浇透
Shure: Indeed, it wasn't soaked through.
Jake:哦要大酒精
Jake: Oh, we need more alcohol.
Jake:那给你买一个呗
Jake: I'll buy you one then.
Jake:让他4020分钟再到
Jake: It will take 40 minutes to get here.
Jake:40分钟再到
Jake: 40 minutes to arrive.
Shure: 就最快最快的酒精
Shure: Just the fastest alcohol.
Shure: 你就搜酒精
Shure: Just search for alcohol.
Shure: 然后最好20分钟就能到那种
Shure: The best would be one that arrives in 20 minutes.
Jake:我给你搜一个美团
Jake: I'll search Meituan for you.
Alice:喷点油行吗
Alice: Can we spray some oil?
Shure: 对美团
Shure: Yeah, Meituan.
Shure: 油够呛真够呛
Shure: Oil might be a bit risky, really risky.
Shure: 或者买药那块
Shure: Or buy from the pharmacy.
Shure: 最快的应该
Shure: That's probably the fastest.
Shure: 卧槽 30是最快
Shure: Whoa, 30 minutes is the fastest.
Shure: 行先整一瓶吧
Shure: Alright, let's get a bottle first.
Jake:看30分钟
Jake: Look, 30 minutes.
Jake:是他先到还是你先着是吧
Jake: Did he arrive first or did you arrive first?
Shure: 先他先
Shure: He arrived first.
Shure: 着还是他先到吧
Shure: Yeah, he arrived first.
Shure: 咱们最起码得吃上啊是吧
Shure: At least we should be able to eat, right?
Alice:yeah
Alice: Yeah.
Tasha: 先到20 呃先到21.7
Tasha: First to 20, uh, first to 21.7.
Tasha: 呃因为我要先加
Tasha: Uh, because I need to add first.
Tasha: 这是不是有点太小了
Tasha: Isn't this a bit too small?
Lucia: 有可能我们要不倒多少
Lucia: Maybe, should we pour a bit more?
Tasha: 分两次
Tasha: In two rounds.
Lucia: 然后取对取下来再那个什么
Lucia: Then take it out and do what?
Lucia: 你是刚好要加两次吗
Lucia: You need to add twice exactly?
Tasha: 我要加三次
Tasha: I need to add three times.
Tasha: 那你倒35克先
Tasha: So pour 35 grams first.
Tasha: 然后剩下的你再倒35
Tasha: Then pour another 35 grams.
Lucia: 34.8可以吗
Lucia: Is 34.8 okay?
Tasha: 可以
Tasha: Okay.
Lucia: 要在这里面
Lucia: Should it be in here?
Lucia: 在在家吗
Lucia: Should we do it at home?
Jake:他说8:50就到了
Jake: He said he would arrive at 8:50.
Alice:我刚才是应该是
Alice: I think it should be...
Lucia: 刚才是35
Lucia: It was 35 just now.
Tasha: 三十五
Tasha: Thirty-five.
Lucia: 那这个这个是要到多少
Lucia: So how much should this one be?
Katrina: 那这个这个啊
Katrina: So this one, huh?
Tasha: 四十啊
Tasha: Forty.
Lucia: 直接到40啊
Lucia: Directly to 40?
Lucia: sorry
Lucia: Sorry.
Alice:怎么样还需要吗
Alice: How about now, do you need more?
Shure: 我觉得这样就可以
Shure: I think this will do.
Shure: 全弄着有希望了
Shure: If we do it all, there's hope.
Shure: 还好今天风是往那边刮
Shure: Fortunately, the wind is blowing that way today.
Shure: 不然呼呼全刮家里了
Shure: Otherwise, it would all blow into the house.
Alice:哈哈没事
Alice: Haha, it's fine.
Alice:家里没啥窗户就封着的
Alice: The house doesn't have many windows, so it's sealed.
Shure: 也是是哪个倒没
Shure: Yeah, which one was it?
Shure: 咱开窗我能告诉他关上吗
Shure: If we open the window, can I tell him to close it?
Alice:那是
Alice: Yeah.
Shure: 啊那是那谁
Shure: Ah, that was... who?
Alice:嗯嗯嗯
Alice: Mm-hmm.
Alice:没事风没往那边吹
Shure: 不行啊
Alice:用大块碳不好着
Shure: 确实
Shure: 到现在还就那一块呢
Shure: 是不
Shure: 他别灭了
Shure: 他他妈还灭了
Shure: 别一会酒精来了我们火没了
Alice:不是没有这个可能
Shure: 我妈远程通过看我
Shure: 这晌告诉我什么放的少了
Katrina: 你妈这能看出来
Jake:啥
Katrina: 你刚那平板的充电宝呢
Shure: 我跟我妈
Tasha: 嗯
Jake:哦哦哦你妈给你指导的是吧
Lucia: 第二回放多少 20还是25
Shure: 对远程指导
Jake:哦可以可以
Jake: Oh, sure, sure.
Jake:为了不断为了不止于羞辱
Jake: To avoid continuous humiliation.
Tasha: 都可以只要最后一共是85就行
Tasha: It's fine as long as the total is 85.
Lucia: 一共85 刚才30啊
Lucia: Total 85, we already have 30.
Shure: 那个呢
Shure: What about that?
Jake:能放油吗
Jake: Can we add oil?
Lucia: 那还差50
Lucia: We're still short 50.
Jake:你这个火
Jake: Your fire...
Lucia: 那就那就2525行吗
Lucia: How about 25 and 25, is that okay?
Shure: 油肯定不能放吧
Shure: We definitely can't add oil.
Tasha: 可以啊
Tasha: Yes, we can.
Jake:行吧
Jake: Fine.
Jake:助然嘛
Jake: Naturally.
Shure: 然后
Shure: Then...
Katrina: 你妈说烧烤粉放少了
Katrina: Your mom said you added too little barbecue powder.
Alice:什么这么呛
Alice: Why is it so choking?
Shure: 他说好看着
Shure: He said to watch carefully.
Shure: 因为正常好像他说是要放酱油的
Shure: Because normally, he said we should add soy sauce.
Shure: 但是我忘记有这个
Shure: But I forgot about that.
Shure: 对然后就是靠酱油带带
Shure: Yeah, so we rely on the soy sauce.
Jake:那就那还能
Jake: Well then, can it still be saved?
Jake:还能救吗
Jake: Can it still be saved?
Alice:带色
Alice: It's colored.
Shure: 不是一个是带色
Shure: No, one is colored.
Shure: 再一个就是咸味嘛
Shure: And the other one is salty.
Alice:咸味儿
Alice: Salty.
Shure: 对
Shure: Right.
Shure: 那就补补点这个呗
Shure: So just add a bit more of this.
Jake:补点吧可以
Jake: Add a bit, okay.
Lucia: 24.9
Jake:来上酱油
Jake: Put in some soy sauce.
Shure: 酱油没有
Shure: We don't have soy sauce.
Shure: 咱们我以为不用
Shure: I thought we didn't need it.
Shure: 所以我就没买你知道吗
Shure: So I didn't buy any, you know?
Jake:哦
Jake: Oh.
Jake:那咋办呢放点盐
Jake: Then what do we do? Put some salt?
Shure: 没事没事
Shure: It's fine, it's fine.
Shure: 就是缺缺这个
Shure: It's just missing this.
Shure: 就补了点烧烤料就差不多
Shure: Just add some barbecue seasoning, that should do.
Jake:行
Jake: Okay.
Shure: 然后
Shure: Then...
Jake:低配版问题不大
Jake: The low-cost version is fine.
Shure: 哎呀
Shure: Oh man.
Jake:为最后一天准备是吧
Jake: Preparing for the last day, right?
Shure: 80%还原了已经
Shure: It's already 80% restored.
Shure: 货不货
Shure: Is it good?
Lucia: 24.8行吗差的不OK
Lucia: 24.8, is it okay? It's not perfect.
Shure: 还有那个
Shure: And then...
Shure: OK
Shure: Okay.
Lucia: 哇这个低筋粉用的还蛮快的咦哈哈
Lucia: Wow, we're using this low-gluten flour pretty fast, huh?
Shure: 那个一会记得也呼了一下
Shure: Remember to call it later too.
Shure: 我再去看外面看看火
Shure: I'll go check the fire outside.
Shure: 好火彻底灭了
Shure: Alright, the fire is completely out.
Shure: 哦你问问管家
Shure: Oh, ask the butler.
Jake:一点火星都不剩
Jake: Not a single spark left.
Shure: 管家能不能帮忙送个酒精啥的
Shure: Can the butler help bring some alcohol or something?
Shure: 应该有你快问一下酒精啥的
Shure: There should be some, quickly ask for alcohol or something.
Shure: 反正最后一天也得用
Shure: Anyway, we'll need it on the last day.
Shure: 你问问管家有没有酒精
Shure: Ask the butler if there's any alcohol.
Shure: 是吗
Shure: Really?
Shure: 那个到哪了瞅一眼
Shure: Where did we get to, let me take a look.
Shure: 点一下完成
Shure: Click to complete.
Shure: OK 9分钟39就能吃上了
Shure: Okay, we'll be able to eat in 9 minutes and 39 seconds.
Shure: 能吃上吧
Shure: We can eat, right?
Lucia: 烤的时间比较久是吗
Lucia: Does it take a long time to roast?
Alice:挪一下
Alice: Move it over a bit.
Lucia: 哇这个这个
Lucia: Wow, this, this...
Lucia: 好像我爸每次炒的牛肉
Lucia: It looks like the beef my dad fries every time.
Lucia: 他就会拌成这样
Lucia: He always mixes it like this.
Lucia: 非常非常像
Lucia: It's very, very similar.
Tasha: 茶包哎
Tasha: Tea bag, hey.
Tasha: 我刚拿了吗
Tasha: Did I just take it?
Lucia: 饿了哈哈哈饿了
Lucia: Hungry, hahaha, hungry.
Alice:好想下手抓一抓
Alice: I really want to grab it with my hands.
Tasha: 然后加哦
Tasha: And then add, oh.
Tasha: 植物油植物油
Tasha: Vegetable oil, vegetable oil.
Tasha: 哎哎这呢
Tasha: Hey, hey, it's here.
Jake:这叫伯爵奶茶是吗
Jake: Is this called Earl Grey milk tea?
Tasha: 油呢油呢哎油呢
Tasha: Oil, where's the oil? Hey, where's the oil?
Tasha: 哎这谁拿到这的
Tasha: Hey, who put this here?
Alice:每件浅色衣服都逃不过
Alice: No light-colored clothes can escape.
Shure: 拿点
Shure: Take some.
Tasha: 好能把搅一下吗
Tasha: Can you stir it a bit?
Tasha: 就是拿筷子搅一下
Tasha: Just use chopsticks to stir it.
Shure: 厨房湿巾在哪
Shure: Where are the kitchen wipes?
Shure: 楼上吗
Shure: Upstairs?
Shure: 啊
Shure: Ah.
Lucia: 等一下我那个
Lucia: Wait a second, my...
Alice:怎么了
Alice: What's wrong?
Lucia: 呃餐巾纸我拿一张
Lucia: Uh, napkin, let me get one.
Lucia: 要不然筷子板上来又没事
Lucia: Otherwise, bringing the chopsticks won't matter.
Lucia: 等一下还没搅完
Lucia: Wait a second, not done stirring.
Lucia: 搞完再弄一下
Lucia: Finish it then stir again.
Lucia: 是要大概搅到啥程度呀
Lucia: To what extent do we need to stir it?
Tasha: 融合就行
Tasha: Just until it blends.
Tasha: 没关系这里面还会再融的
Tasha: It's okay, it will blend more inside.
Lucia: 啊这俩要要要融合可能要
Lucia: Ah, these two need to blend, maybe need...
Shure: 把那个一会烤架给擦一下
Shure: Wipe the grill later.
Jake:这好融啊
Jake: It blends well.
Tasha: 好了
Tasha: Done.
Lucia: 哈哈先把牛顿
Lucia: Haha, let's start with Newton.
Jake:哈哈哈这怎么融化
Jake: Hahaha, how do we melt this?
Lucia: 哈哈哈
Lucia: Hahaha.
Lucia: 但是这个这个原理是牛顿发现的
Lucia: But this principle was discovered by Newton.
Jake:不管他不管不管
Jake: Doesn't matter, doesn't matter.
Lucia: 不管他反正对
Lucia: Doesn't matter, anyway, yeah.
Jake:反正物理有物理的问题
Jake: Physics has its own problems anyway.
Jake:对对对
Jake: Yeah, yeah, exactly.
Alice:擦完之后是不是还得洗
Alice: After wiping, do we need to wash it?
Alice:这上面可是洗洁精之类的那种东西
Alice: This has dish soap or something on it.
Alice:你却也能吃肚子里
Alice: You're going to eat it like that?
Shure: 拿这个过来一下
Shure: Bring this over here for a second.
Shure: 没问题真的
Shure: No problem, really.
Alice:真的吗
Alice: Really?
Alice:要不洗一下吧
Alice: How about we wash it?
Shure: 方便的话就冲一下
Shure: If it's convenient, just rinse it.
Shure: 因为这个基本就是干净的啊
Shure: Because it's basically clean.
Shure: 确实稍微冲一下
Shure: Yeah, just rinse it a bit.
Shure: 谢谢你
Shure: Thank you.
Shure: 已经饿的不行了是吗哈哈
Shure: Are you so hungry you can't wait? Haha.
Alice:一般
Alice: Not really.
Shure: 卧槽有的着了居然有两块红了已经
Shure: Oh wow, some of it got burnt, there are already two pieces that are red.
Alice:大的小的
Alice: Big or small?
Shure: 大的
Shure: Big ones.
Alice:牛逼
Alice: Awesome.
Lucia: 呃对那天微微解释一下他怎么用的
Lucia: Uh, yeah, that day Tasha explained how to use it.
Lucia: 但是其实我也没搞明白
Lucia: But honestly, I didn't really get it.
Lucia: 反正总之就是这样用的
Lucia: Anyway, that's how you use it.
Jake:什么时候切
Jake: When do we cut it?
Tasha: 等会就切
Tasha: We'll cut it in a bit.
Tasha: 你要切吗
Tasha: Do you want to cut it?
Alice:我的边边呢
Alice: Where's my edge piece?
Alice:来了
Alice: Here it is.
Shure: 行先放那就行
Shure: Okay, just put it there.
Shure: 这还没没没咋地呢
Shure: It's not a big deal.
Shure: 放下说问题不大
Shure: Put it down, it's not a big issue.
Alice:这桌干净的吗
Alice: Is this table clean?
Shure: 基本干净
Shure: Pretty clean.
Shure: 放了
Shure: Put it down.
Shure: 有两块着了
Shure: Two pieces got burnt.
Jake:哦那就有戏啊
Jake: Oh, then there's hope.
Alice:有戏对哪两花啊
Alice: Hope for which two flowers?
Alice:先天打工圣体这是
Alice: This is an innate worker's holy body.
Shure: 他俩很着急
Shure: They are in a hurry.
Shure: 然后我们还有一个非常重要素材就是
Shure: And we have a very important piece of material...
Shure: 哦看到了看到了
Shure: Oh, I see it, I see it.
Alice:玩不上
Alice: It won't work.
Jake:这就整完了
Jake: It's all done.
Jake:就剩烤了
Jake: Just need to bake it.
Jake:这是预热过的
Jake: It's preheated.
Jake:烤40分钟
Jake: Bake for 40 minutes.
Tasha: 嗯
Tasha: Hmm.
Jake:就等着就行了嗯
Jake: Just wait, that's all, hmm.
Tasha: 然后再打发个奶油就行
Tasha: Then whip some cream.
Tasha: 但是奶油打发等它快烤出来再打就行
Tasha: But whip the cream when it's almost done baking.
Shure: 咱们最后一天是周一还是周日来着
Shure: Is our last day Monday or Sunday?
Jake:周日哎
Jake: Sunday, hey.
Jake:周周一周日搞完活动周一
Jake: We'll finish the event on Sunday, Monday...
Jake:呃划划水
Jake: Uh, relax a bit.
Shure: 哦
Shure: Oh.
Jake:复个盘拆屋子
Jake: Review and dismantle the house.
Tasha: 我们结束了
Tasha: We're done.
Jake:把屋子拆了
Jake: Take down the house.
Tasha: 这个还要小
Tasha: This one still needs to be smaller.
Tasha: 没事了
Tasha: It's fine.
Tasha: 这个洗了等会打奶油用
Tasha: Wash this, we'll use it for whipping cream later.
Lucia: 打奶
Lucia: Whip cream.
Alice:我洗个筷子
Alice: I'll wash the chopsticks.
Alice:这是干净的碗把
Alice: Is this a clean bowl?
Tasha: 嗯应该是吧
Tasha: Hmm, I think so.
Alice:多少电了
Alice:去上个厕所
Alice: I'm going to the restroom.
Alice:先放一下
Alice: Just put it here for now.
Shure: 配和你走到山顶
Shure: Walk with you to the mountaintop.
Katrina: 去外面是吗
Katrina: Going outside?
Shure: 对
Shure: Yes.
Jake:半毛半毛新币
Jake: Half a new coin.
Lucia: 好像是
Lucia: Seems like it.
Jake:5毛新币
Jake: Five new coins.
Lucia: 不记得了
Lucia: I don't remember.
Shure: 不行我也饿了得赶紧
Shure: No way, I'm hungry, we need to hurry.
Jake:是
Jake: Yes.
Lucia: 但是你可以试试看
Lucia: But you can give it a try.
Jake:简单的快乐
Jake: Simple joy.
Lucia: 哦
Lucia: Oh.
Tasha: 然后你把蛋糕放在这
Tasha: Then you put the cake here.
Tasha: 然后这样子过去
Tasha: Then move it like this.
Jake:哦
Jake: Oh.
Tasha: 好等会你来展示
Tasha: Okay, you'll demonstrate later.
Jake:好的交给我吧
Jake: Alright, leave it to me.
Jake:我先切一个土豆试一试
Jake: I'll try cutting a potato first.
Tasha: 如果说你们想要切三层对吧
Tasha: If you want to cut three layers, right?
Tasha: 那那你可能就要在第一层
Tasha: Then you might want to start with the first layer,
Tasha: 第三层和最上面一层
Tasha: third layer, and the topmost layer.
Jake:嗯没问题
Jake: No problem.
Tasha: 这样子就可以切出来
Tasha: This way you can cut it out.
Jake:没问题
Jake: No problem.
Jake:我先试试
Jake: Let me try first.
Tasha: 不是还要加芒果吗
Tasha: Don't you still need to add mango?
Tasha: 然后我们可以一层芒果夹心
Tasha: Then we can have a layer of mango filling.
Jake:嗯
Jake: Mm.
Tasha: 一层奶油夹心
Tasha: A layer of cream filling.
Katrina: 啊好好吃
Katrina: Ah, so tasty.
Tasha: 然后一层草莓夹心等等
Tasha: Then a layer of strawberry filling, etc.
Jake:然后一层
Jake: Then a layer.
Jake:哦好好好
Jake: Oh, okay, okay.
Lucia: 啊
Lucia: Ah.
Jake:怎么做啊
Jake: How do you do it?
Jake:那就切草莓
Jake: Then cut the strawberry.
Jake:切芒果的是吧
Jake: And the mango, right?
Tasha: 你不是说尽量把芒果消灭掉吗
Tasha: Didn't you say to use up the mango as much as possible?
Jake:就是就是把它切成碎
Jake: Yes, just cut it into pieces.
Lucia: 啊
Lucia: Ah.
Tasha: 豆和巧克力豆夹心夹层
Tasha: Bean and chocolate chip fillings.
Tasha: 所以大家要吃什么夹层
Tasha: So whatever filling everyone wants.
Tasha: 就夹什么夹层就行了
Tasha: Just add whatever filling you like.
Katrina: 天好幸福
Katrina: So happy.
Lucia: 哇哦
Lucia: Wow.
Katrina: 芒果的芒
Katrina: Mango madness.
Alice:芒果
Alice: Mango.
Jake:有点厉害
Jake: Pretty impressive.
Jake:芒果在这
Jake: The mango is here.
Jake:我要怎么准备它
Jake: How should I prepare it?
Tasha: 把皮削了
Tasha: Peel the skin off.
Tasha: 然后你如果想吃大块的你就不切
Tasha: If you want to eat big chunks, don't cut it.
Tasha: 就直接一片一片的加进去
Tasha: Just add it in slice by slice.
Jake:好我先去拿个酒精
Jake: Okay, I'll go get some alcohol first.
Tasha: 如果你想吃芒果丁你就全部都切成丁
Tasha: If you want diced mango, just cut it all into cubes.
Jake:好嘞好好好没问题
Jake: Alright, alright, no problem.
Tasha: 敷衍
Tasha: Half-hearted.
Jake:哎你好
Jake: Hey, how are you?
Jake:好来了来了来了嘿
Jake: Alright, coming, coming, hey!
Tasha: 嗯我要吃肉哈哈
Tasha: Hmm, I want to eat meat, haha.
Shure: 酱油料酒都得放
Shure: You need to add soy sauce and cooking wine.
Lucia: 那等一下
Lucia: Wait a second.
Lucia: 他们应该很快就可以考了
Lucia: They should be done soon.
Tasha: 嗯
Tasha: Hmm.
Tasha: 一个蛋糕会不会太少了要不要在烤店
Tasha: Would one cake be too little? Should we bake more?
Tasha: 纸杯的反正也很简单
Tasha: Cupcakes are simple anyway.
Lucia: 都可以你决定
Lucia: Either is fine, you decide.
Jake:谢谢您再见
Jake: Thank you, goodbye.
Tasha: 所以那天的量是10个的量
Tasha: So, we need to make ten of them that day.
Tasha: 所以还是考10个就行了
Tasha: So, just bake ten then.
Shure: 呼呼呼呼呼
Shure: Hoo hoo hoo hoo hoo.
Jake:哈哈哈来吧
Jake: Hahaha, let's go.
Tasha: 超级简单这个
Tasha: This is super easy.
Lucia: 也可以如果如果
Lucia: You can if...
Lucia: 今天晚上吃不
Lucia: Tonight...
Lucia: 完的话
Lucia: If...
Lucia: 冷藏到明天早上当早饭也可以是吗
Lucia: We can't finish it tonight, we can refrigerate it and have it for breakfast tomorrow, right?
Tasha: 可以吧
Tasha: I think so.
Lucia: 好呀
Lucia: Okay, great.
Shure: 哎
Shure: Hey.
Lucia: 不会那个什么
Lucia: It won't...
Tasha: 嗯应该可以吧
Tasha: Hmm, it should be fine.
Tasha: 那只需要把这个擦干就行了
Tasha: Just need to wipe this dry.
Tasha: 然后我们嗯
Tasha: And then we...
Tasha: 完全看不见他的状态
Tasha: Can't see his status at all.
Tasha: 我干错了我挑战一下他
Tasha: I did it wrong, I'll challenge him.
Tasha: 对所以哎呀完了有一张纸掉上去了
Tasha: Right, so... oh no, a piece of paper fell on it.
Lucia: 拿筷子剪出来行吗
Lucia: Can we use chopsticks to pick it out?
Tasha: 嗯可以我就感觉他太靠上了
Tasha: Hmm, okay, I just feel like it's too high up.
Lucia: 哎刚刚用的那根筷子上哪去
Lucia: Hey, where did the chopsticks we just used go?
Tasha: 所以想要挑
Tasha: So I want to adjust it.
Lucia: 是不是已经被洗了
Lucia: Did it get washed already?
Lucia: 擦一下
Lucia: Wipe it off.
Lucia: 要不要把底下这层撤了
Lucia: Should we remove this bottom layer?
Lucia: 然后光放一层
Lucia: And just leave one layer?
Tasha: 对我刚刚想的也是把它放在
Tasha: Yeah, I was thinking of placing it
Tasha: 蛋糕雏形
Tasha: as a cake shape.
Lucia: 拆一下
Lucia: Take it apart.
Tasha: OK
Tasha: OK.
Alice:酒精送到了
Alice: The alcohol has arrived.
Lucia: 多么甜蜜
Lucia: How sweet.
Alice:酒精是不是送到了
Alice: Has the alcohol arrived?
Jake:到了
Jake: Yes, it has.
Shure: 送到了
Shure: It's here.
Shure: 接着这个把这个先点着
Shure: Let's light this up first.
Shure: 好像点不着他似的你要不
Shure: Seems like it won't light up, can you...
Shure: 要不借着这个你再去
Shure: Maybe you can use this and go to...
Shure: 那个屋里去
Shure: that room to light it up.
Shure: 屋里再烧一下子
Shure: Light it up in that room.
Alice:我
Alice: I...
Shure: 对交给你了
Shure: Yes, it's up to you.
Shure: 咱先等他静候他
Shure: Let's wait for it quietly.
Jake:咱是不是打个火
Jake: Should we light a fire?
Jake:买个火机是不是也挺好的哈哈哈
Jake: Buying a lighter would be good too, hahaha.
Shure: 哈哈哈
Shure: Hahaha.
Shure: 就单核摘
Shure: Just a single core.
Shure: 县城没有工人就是不行
Shure: It's tough without workers in the county.
Alice:哎呦我的天呐
Alice: Oh my gosh.
Alice:别吸了
Alice: Stop inhaling.
Alice:来煽风点火了
Alice: Come on, fan the flames.
Shure: 着了吗
Shure: Is it lit?
Alice:桥的嘛嘚
Alice: It's lit.
Jake:我来切哦
Jake: I'll cut it.
Shure: OK
Shure: OK.
Alice:圣火来了
Alice: The sacred fire is here.
Shure: 慢慢慢慢来慢慢来
Shure: Slowly, slowly, take it slow.
Shure: 再慢点再慢点再慢点OK
Shure: Even slower, even slower, OK.
Shure: 稳住稳住
Shure: Steady, steady.
Shure: 给他立起来点
Shure: Lift it up a bit.
Shure: 立起来点
Shure: Lift it higher.
Shure: OK OK好好
Shure: OK OK, good.
Alice:不许来风
Alice: No wind allowed.
Shure: 给他
Shure: Give it to him.
Alice:喷点酒精
Alice: Spray some alcohol.
Shure: 直接浇灭
Shure: Just pour it out.
Alice:牛逼再来吧
Alice: Awesome, let's do it again.
Alice:还有没了
Alice: Anymore?
Alice:我刚才见了这
Alice: I just saw it here.
Shure: 别一会酒精用没了卧槽
Shure: Don't waste all the alcohol, damn.
Alice:来吧我的板
Alice: Here, take my board.
Alice:这次不许来火了
Alice: This time, no fire.
Alice:不对不许来水了
Alice: Wait, no water.
Alice:不对不许来风了
Alice: No, no wind.
Jake:嗯好谢谢
Jake: Hmm, okay, thanks.
Lucia: 哈哈哈哈
Lucia: Hahahaha.
Alice:圣火
Alice: Holy fire.
Alice:圣火降临
Alice: The holy fire descends.
Alice:卧槽
Alice: Damn.
Alice:好好好我怕爆炸哈哈
Alice: Alright, alright, so scared of explosions, haha.
Jake:是这是逐步探索边界
Jake: Yeah, this is like pushing the boundaries.
Alice:你可小心点
Alice: Be careful.
Alice:别别顺着你的皮烧着你了
Alice: Don't let it burn your skin.
Alice:卧槽太爽了吧这
Alice: Damn, this is so cool.
Shure: 帅吧
Shure: Cool, right?
Shure: 此刻已成艺术
Shure: It's art now.
Alice:那那夹子呢
Alice: Where are the tongs?
Alice:你夹子去哪了
Alice: Where did the tongs go?
Shure: BB着了这不可能
Shure: The tongs are burnt? No way.
Shure: 不着了吧这
Shure: Probably not.
Alice:你夹子呢
Alice: Where are the tongs?
Shure: 嗯
Shure: Hmm.
Alice:那夹子
Alice: The tongs.
Jake:谁
Jake: Who?
Shure: 那夹子我刚才随地扔到
Shure: I just tossed the tongs somewhere.
Alice:哦我知道了
Alice: Oh, I see.
Shure: 因为酒精牛逼
Shure: Because alcohol is awesome.
Shure: 不会
Shure: No way.
Alice:这俩腿打架啊
Alice: These legs are fighting.
Shure: 酒精烧完了他都没烧吧
Shure: The alcohol burned out, but it didn't really burn, right?
Shure: 完了完了
Shure: It's over, it's over.
Jake:完了原来是纸的
Jake: Oh no, it was actually paper.
Alice:不耐烧
Alice: Not resistant to burning.
Shure: 实在烧实在烧了
Shure: It's really burning now.
Jake:纸在烧我以为碳全烧起来了
Jake: The paper is burning, I thought the charcoal was all burning.
Shure: 他们确实烧起来了
Shure: They are definitely burning.
Jake:哦小烧起
Jake: Oh, it's starting to burn a little.
Shure: 我们应该给底下垫一层纸壳
Shure: We should put a layer of cardboard underneath.
Jake:来
Jake: Come on.
Shure: 然后纸壳一直在烧的话
Shure: And if the cardboard keeps burning,
Shure: 他就应该可以拿回去干吧
Shure: we should be able to take it back, right?
Jake:那我们这么干吧
Jake: Let's do it this way.
Jake:我们有足够的纸
Jake: We have enough paper.
Shure: 可以
Shure: Okay.
Shure: 找一个够长的
Shure: Find one long enough.
Shure: 这绝对够长拿一下
Shure: This is definitely long enough, take it.
Shure: 你们现在都是古希腊掌管圣火的女神
Shure: You guys are like the Greek goddesses tending the sacred fire now.
Alice:哦对不起火灭了
Alice: Oh, sorry, the fire's out.
Katrina: 这是酒精吗哪来的
Katrina: Is this alcohol? Where did it come from?
Shure: 是的
Shure: Yes.
Shure: 然后这个怎么给他烧着呢卧槽
Shure: So how do we get it to light up? Damn.
Alice:能给他引着吗行不行
Alice: Can we light it up? Can it work?
Alice:上纸板
Alice: Put the cardboard on.
Alice:又没火了又
Alice: The fire's out again.
Alice:这些明显就一点点
Alice: There's only a tiny bit left.
Shure: 累死了妈妈
Shure: I'm exhausted, mom.
Alice:哈哈哈
Alice: Hahaha.
Alice:哎我的妈
Alice:没事，这个
Alice:那个小子呢
Alice: Where's that kid?
Alice:那个酒精呢
Alice: Where's that alcohol?
Alice:还有一点点火
Alice: There's still a little bit of fire.
Alice:不知道能给它弄着不
Alice: Don't know if we can light it.
Alice:确实
Alice: Indeed.
Alice:行吧
Alice: Alright then.
Alice:没有明火是不行的
Alice: Without open flames, it won't work.
Shure: 我们可以这样
Shure: We can do it like this.
Alice:会有点危险
Alice: It might be a bit dangerous.
Alice:哈哈哈
Alice: Hahaha.
Alice:这上面我有一点点酒精
Alice: I have a little bit of alcohol here.
Alice:哈哈哈
Alice: Hahaha.
Alice:笑死
Alice: Laughing to death.
Alice:送入烤箱
Alice: Put it in the oven.
Alice:给他弄灭了吧
Alice: Let's put it out.
Shure: 奶奶个腿的
Shure: Damn it.
Shure: 我真不信
Shure: I really don't believe it.
Shure: 原来也没这么难找过这些东西
Shure: It used to be easier to find these things.
Shure: 不行我们考9,100
Shure: No way, we need to aim for 9,100.
Shure: 哈哈考他
Shure: Haha, let's test him.
Alice:这得多少酒精烧啊
Alice: How much alcohol will it take to burn this?
Shure: 确实
Shure: Indeed.
Shure: 帅不帅哈哈哈哈
Shure: Is it cool or what? Hahaha.
Katrina: 像魔术师一样
Katrina: Like a magician.
Alice:哈哈哈
Alice: Hahaha.
Katrina: 好搞笑啊
Katrina: So funny.
Katrina: 特别是他在那打仗
Katrina: Especially when he's fighting there.
Alice:等一下你到最后一点
Alice: Wait, you're almost there.
Alice:给你照个相
Alice: Let me take a picture.
Shure: 来
Shure: Come on.
Alice:等等等稍等一下
Alice: Wait, wait, hold on a sec.
Katrina: 特别像在表演魔术
Katrina: It really looks like a magic show.
Shure: 你一定要刷的帅一下
Shure: You have to make it look cool.
Alice:好
Alice: Okay.
Shure: 很帅起来
Shure: Lookin' good.
Alice:哈哈哈
Alice: Hahaha.
Alice:烧点硬盘
Alice: Burn some hard drives.
Shure: 他们都只红了一点点
Shure: They only got a little red.
Alice:有个小夹呢
Alice: Is there a small clip?
Shure: 这不行这不行
Shure: This won't work, this won't work.
Shure: 不能这么少
Shure: Can't be this little.
Shure: 这么烧肯他妈的要出事
Shure: Burning like this is definitely gonna cause trouble.
Alice:聊胜于无吧
Alice: Better than nothing, right?
Shure: 卧槽这烧的快啊
Shure: Damn, it burns fast.
Shure: 这呼一下就烧起来了
Shure: It just whooshed and caught fire.
Shure: 嗯这烧透了
Shure: Yeah, it's burned through.
Shure: 还是这书就是刚才
Shure: Or maybe the book was already burning.
Shure: 原来那本来就烧起来的
Shure: It was already catching fire.
Shure: 看今天是8,000美金先报
Shure: Look, today it's 8,000 dollars to start.
Shure: 还是我们先吃上饭好吧
Shure: Let's eat first, okay?
Alice:不在那边一会那个火星泼你身上
Alice: Don't stay over there, the sparks might splash on you.
Shure: 人生没有容易2字懂了吗
Shure: Life isn't easy, got it?
Katrina: 哈哈哈哈
Katrina: Hahaha.
Shure: 这时候现在知道谁知盘中餐
Shure: Now you know how hard it is to get food on the table.
Shure: 粒粒皆辛苦了吧
Shure: Every grain is hard work, right?
Tasha: 好对
Tasha: Yeah, totally.
Shure: 妈妈说你快远离这个是非之地
Shure: Mom said you should stay away from trouble.
Alice:看就差不多了
Alice: Looks about right.
Shure: 对其实差不多了
Shure: Yeah, it's pretty much done.
Alice:你就搁那别动就行
Alice: Just stay there and don't move.
Alice:妈这样显得我像个小丑
Alice: Mom, this makes me look like a clown.
Alice:我觉得可以上烤盘了
Alice: I think it's ready for the grill.
Shure: 是吗
Shure: Really?
Alice:嗯还挺烧的
Alice: Yeah, it's pretty hot.
Katrina: 特别可怜
Katrina: So pitiful.
Alice:还挺热的了
Alice: It's quite hot now.
Alice:好就这样吧
Alice: Alright, let's do it.
Shure: 这也着了
Shure: This is burning too.
Alice:你试试这个温度上
Alice: You try the temperature.
Shure: 确实
Shure: Indeed.
Alice:上吧上吧
Alice: Go ahead, go ahead.
Alice:哎呀我来
Alice: Let me do it.
Shure: 不行就多烤会呗
Shure: If it doesn't work, just grill it longer.
Shure: 咱慢慢熏
Shure: Let's take our time.
Alice:小火慢煨
Alice: Slow cook on low heat.
Shure: 对
Shure: Exactly.
Shure: 我终于知道
Shure: I finally understand.
Shure: 我爸为什么每次都不买这种长条
Shure: Why my dad never buys these long ones.
Shure: 他说易燃
Shure: He said they're flammable.
Shure: 但是根本就一点都不易燃
Shure: But they're not flammable at all.
Shure: 都是假的
Shure: It's all fake.
Shure: 这一点没着的
Shure: This isn't burning at all.
Alice:其实我觉得可以放上去
Alice: Actually, I think we can put it up.
Alice:你试一下这个温度
Alice: Try the temperature.
Shure: 来吧先咱们小范围烤着
Shure: Let's grill a small part first.
Shure: 烤着一点吃
Shure: Grill and eat a bit.
Shure: 好吧不然话真快饿死了大家
Shure: Otherwise, everyone will starve soon.
Shure: 是的是的肯定有用
Shure: Yes, yes, it will definitely work.
Shure: 只要鼓鼓手的手速
Shure: As long as the drummer's hand speed.
Shure: 这时候就能用上了
Shure: It can be used now.
Shure: 咱不有吹风机吗
Shure: Don't we have a hairdryer?
Shure: 啊也是
Shure: Ah, right.
Shure: 从从那个屋顺出一个插排
Shure: Let's get an extension cord from that room.
Alice:你去准备那啥吧我扇会
Alice: You go prepare that, I'll fan for a bit.
Alice:哎是不是这个就可以用了
Alice: Hey, can we use this one?
Katrina: 学了呀我今天还学了
Katrina: I learned it, I learned it today.